FATHER.
>> Martha: THAT IS OUR STORY
FOR TONIGHT, WE'LL SEE YOU BACK
HERE TOMORROW NIGHT.
TUCKER IS UP NEXT.
>> Tucker: COULD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
ALL INDICATIONS OUT OF
WASHINGTON SUGGEST THAT MILITARY
STRIKES AGAINST SYRIA COULD BE
IMMINENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETED AS MUCH
AS MORNING WARNING SERIOUS ALLY
RUSSIA TO GET READY BECAUSE
MISSILES "WILL BE COMING.
NICE AND NEW AND SMART."
SPEAKING OF SMART, FIVE YEARS
AGO AND RESPONSE TO THE LACK OF
ADMINISTRATION'S PLANS TO BOMB
SYRIA, TRUMP TWEETED THIS.
"BE PREPARED, THERE'S A SMALL
CHANCE ARE HORRENDOUS LEADERSHIP
COULD UNKNOWINGLY LEAD US INTO
WORLD WAR III."
THAT WAS A WISE RESPONSE, THE
KIND THAT COULD GET YOU ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND YET, HERE WE ARE ONCE AGAIN
ON THE BRINK OF SOMETHING THAT
WAS OUTLINED AND CONSEQUENCES
THAT ARE UNKNOWABLE AND
TERRIFYING.
ON MONDAY NIGHT, WE SPENT MORE
THAN 50 MINUTES TALKING ABOUT
THAT.
WE ASKED WHAT SEEM LIKE MOST